Avengers: Endgame​ left the stories of many
of our favorite heroes up in the air, but
perhaps none so much as Mark Ruffalo's Bruce
Banner.
Fans of the Green Goliath would love to know:
is Banner going to play a part in the ​Disney+
She-Hulk​ limited series, or what?
Well, we have no way of knowing for sure,
but the short answer is: it's pretty likely.
Not only would it make narrative sense, but
it would give Marvel Studios the opportunity
to continue to capitalize on the Hulk without
needing to worry about his film rights.
It's well-known that in the '90s, at a time
when Marvel Comics was in serious financial
jeopardy, the publisher sold the film rights
to many of its most beloved characters: Spider-Man
went to Sony Pictures, while the X-Men, the
Fantastic Four, and many of their associated
characters wound up at Fox Studios.
Spider-Man had a five-film run during the
brief period of time that Marvel and Sony
were able to play ball, while the Fox-owned
properties are only now being prepped for
entry into the franchise following the acquisition
of Fox by Marvel's parent company, Disney.
But many casual fans are unaware that the
MCU had been impacted from the very beginning
by a third deal: the one that Marvel made
with Universal for the Hulk's film rights.
That's how the Ang Lee 2003 Hulk was made,
and the agreement is also the reason why 2008's
The Incredible Hulk was distributed by Universal.
The studio had secured the film rights to
the Green Goliath in the early '00s, but only
for the 2003 film.
Following that, the studio retained "right
of first refusal" to distribute, not produce,
any solo Hulk picture.
Universal retains the right to distribute
any future Hulk movies, from now until the
end of time, and as far as Disney is concerned,
this simply won't do.
Nothing in that deal, though, says that Marvel
can't use the Hulk as a supporting character
— which is why Bruce Banner has been featured
in team-up films since the Disney acquisition.
So, considering this history, it seems likely
that Marvel Studios can use Banner as a supporting
character in She-Hulk if they want to do so.
It's unclear whether Universal's deal with
Marvel covered the character's television
rights at all, but, considering that Universal
hasn't even attempted to make a Hulk TV project
in the last couple of decades, we're thinking
that it did not.
Of course, it's likely that Banner is involved
on some level, since She-Hulk's entire origin
revolves around her cousin.
In the comics, Walters' superpowers comes
from a blood transfusion given to her by her
cousin after the young, crusading attorney
was shot and grievously wounded by gangsters.
Obviously, this scenario will probably be
updated in some way, but it would be pretty
hard to come up with an origin for She-Hulk
which excludes the original Jade Giant.
Including Banner in the events of She-Hulk
would also help to tie up several narrative
loose ends, including those left dangling
by The Incredible Hulk.
Is Emil Blonsky, AKA the Abomination, still
sitting in the Raft plotting his revenge?
Did Samuel Stearns become the Leader, or did
that weird mutation going on with his head
just kind of peter out?
We also submit that, although Banner's arc
was indeed wrapped up pretty satisfactorily
by the events of Endgame, he didn't exactly
get an tear-jerking, iconic sendoff like Stark
and Rogers did.
It'd be nice if he could be given a proper
goodbye, while at the same time passing the
torch to a new Hulk.
At any rate, we'll all just have to stay tuned
for an official announcement, but we're pretty
sure that Ruffalo's Bruce Banner will figure
prominently in the She-Hulk Disney+ series.
We'll be keeping an eye out for any news to
come, and we'll keep you up to speed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.